今天的课程是由新诗入门探讨所谓创作风格
先来朗诵一首韵脚诗
希望你们会慢慢喜欢这样子的一个创作的形
式跟风格
今天要分享的韵脚师名字叫宠猫日记
相信很多人家里都有猫猫狗狗
那猫猫狗狗是人类的一个心灵的伴侣
为什么叫心灵的伴侣才会抚慰疗愈你的身心
所以家里有宠物的很幸福
我们家就有两只猫
一只叫多多
一只叫抱抱豹豹
身价不菲
它是传说中的豹猫
当初买的时候还蛮贵的
差不多可能1万以上的人民币
然后呢后来又领养了一只领养的领养的猫
它会送饲料
你知道吗
然后领养的那只猫是不用钱
而且还送饲料
然后这两只猫在家里面打架的时候
领养的那只叫多多
它会欺负那只身价不菲的猫叫包包
他们彼此不晓得对方的身价
所以觉得蛮有趣的好
那分享这首宠猫日记
猫出现在诗里
我每读一行都极其细腻
可以检验出你的气味
刚刚经过这里
猫一直出现在诗里
我每翻一页都屏住呼吸
生怕惊飞的你
脚步声很轻的美丽
猫一直都出现在诗里
我每看一篇都小心翼翼触摸
张杰中温驯如绒毛般的字句
猫一直都频繁地出现在诗里
而我也终于吞噬掉整本诗集
不让别人读
你由新诗入门探讨所谓创作风格
为什么要从诗呢
因为对我而言
诗的语言洁净度远远高过于大多数的格子
记得是大多数
那用诗来入门
一开始的门槛就比较高
这是一种创作上的选择
我们不要去选择比较轻易的事情
那要选择歌词创作
那必须从相对应比较难的文体上去做吸收
所以呢我们今天分享了两个诗人的作品
这两位诗人的创作类型非常的悬殊
所有的文字结构都非常的不一样
你可以看出里面独立的一种所谓风格
那接下来我们探讨什么叫风格
风格就是艺术的概念
风格可以决定艺术生长的样貌
作品的风格它必须有一个一致性
所有的一致性是你看到这个艺术创作诶
这好像是谁的作品
他就有一个一致性
他就有个面貌
有个表情
这个表情是非常非常重要的
因为创作的东西或者是信息量太大了
当谁也记不住谁的创作时
你的东西如果有独特的表情风格
你可以理解成作品的表情或所谓的气质
气质可能比较好
说明一个人的气质是不会更改的
他可能今天心情不好
脸臭臭的
或者是说他今天心情很开心
讲话和颜悦色
但这些不是他的妻子
气质是不会变的
他可能今天穿的丑一点
邋遢一点
穿的时尚一点
摩登一点
但是气质是贯穿的
所以作品的风格也就是一个人的气质
那风格怎么去形容呢
怎么去形容所有独特面貌的风格
或者是作品的表情呢
通常依赖创作者本身的先天
他成长的环境
他所受的教育
这些教育跟成长的环境
会某部分刑诉这个人创作的风格
再是他后天的吸收
后天的吸收就是主动的
他对于什么东西有兴趣
他的性格的倾向
他的新局面的反应会在作品上很具象的呈现
那这个就是所谓的风格
而且风格必须很稳定
必须是内在的
而不是特色
作品的特色不等于风格
这个很重要诶
他这个作品很有特色哦
切记特色不是风格
特色有点像这个人这一次的穿着
这次的穿着哦
可能有点独会风
有点波西米亚风
但不是这个人的气质或是这个人的个性
因此你要个很稳定
有一致性的创作表情跟面貌跟气质
这个叫风格
像我个人创作的韵脚是就具备了所谓的风格
因为他创作的表情非常的明显
他的气质很稳定
当我在朗诵韵脚诗的时候
它有个节奏感
而且注意哦
就是像刚刚那首最后一样不让别人读
你就是我不让别人有接触你的机会
因为你喜欢的对象会有个专属感
会有个私心
你不希望别人太多的了解他
所以我每一首的韵脚诗
重点的核心跟整篇的一个起承转合的峰回路转
都放在最后的一行或一句
风格的建立是需要累积的
是需要大量的作品去行诉你个人作品
清晰的表情
而这个清晰的表情就会变成你个人创作的
一种所谓的风格
所以呢今天我们要先理清了什么叫风格
之所以不选择歌词来做这堂课的风格建立
而是用所谓的诗
是因为重视歌词的一个书写的题材
在某些领域里面也被认知为文学的题材
但是我以词作者的身份很严肃的告诉大家
多数的歌词偏口语
偏情绪
遣词用语太平铺直述
基本上我还是坚持他是文字作品
那我就用告白气球
这首我自己的创作来做一个解释
比较不会伤及无辜
告白气球的副歌是亲爱的
爱上你
从那天起甜蜜的很轻易
亲爱的
别任性
你的眼睛在说我愿意
我想请问大家
这个有文学的意涵吗
有文学的感觉吗
其实并没有
所以呢我只能说大多数的歌词作品
我认为是不能归类为文学作品
它只能算是文字作品
我们学习事物
要把更好的东西当做一个目标去追求
也因此这堂课我用心思来类比风格的建立
而不是用歌词
因为诗对我来讲很特别
像风景如画
景色如诗就很特别诶居然丝可以用来形容风景
不会有人用歌词来形容风景
就是景色如歌词是不可能的
因为诗有一个很巨大的信息量
它可以变成形容词
譬如说诶这个舞台剧哇
感觉上很像是立体诗哇
这部电影很像是影像诗
或是这个设计风格很像是一首空间诗
你在对事物做一个判断跟形容词的时候
觉得很美
很浪漫的环境
你会想到诗诗歌的诗
新诗的诗
但是其实你不会想到歌词
这个就是诗跟词巨大的差异
诗跟无限的延伸跟想象
还有解释的空间跟意涵
也因此这堂课我觉得用诗来做一个风格的建立
跟说明会比词要好得多
而且让葛同学可以领略和欣赏不同的文
自美
接下来要分享这两位诗人呢
做个人非常喜欢的一个作者
一个是夏雨
一个是席慕蓉
因为每个人的作品都会有一个相互左右的因素
那这个相互作用的因素
可能在你学习成长的过程中
无形中就吸收了谁的风格
慢慢在行诉与建立自己的风格
但起码你要有一个东西可以学习
你要有个目标可以追求
也因此呢我求学阶段除了宋词
也就是李清照
李煜的词
另外现代诗基本上在求学阶段
中学时期我很喜欢席慕蓉的诗
他有一首很著名的诗就叫七里香
我之前不是创作一首七里香吗
说实在名字受他的影响
但是内容完全不一样
溪流急着流向海洋
浪潮却渴望重回土地
在绿树白花的篱前
曾那样轻易地挥手道别
而沧桑的20年后
我们的魂魄却夜夜归来
微风拂过时便化作满园的郁香
很简短
你不觉得很很清很清爽嘛
就是听完之后好像闻到花的味道了
好接下来再分享下一首
都是比较偏短的诗作
这首诗叫小静破晓的小镜子的镜
我以为我已经帮你藏好了
藏在那样深那样冷的昔日的心底
我以为只要绝口不提
只要让日子继续地过去
你就会终于终于变成一个古老的秘密
可是不眠的夜仍然太长
而早生的白发又泄露了我的悲伤
你们不觉得这个悲伤也是轻轻柔柔的吗
他不是很剧烈的悲伤
不是很沉痛的悲伤
这个就是他诗的风格
甜蜜也罢
悲伤也好
都是轻轻柔柔
没有负担的这样子一个诗作风格很鲜明
再来分享最后一首青春
所有的结局都已经写好
所有的泪水也都已启程
却忽然忘了是怎么样的一个开始
在那个古老的不再回来的夏日
无论我如何地去追索
年轻的你
只如云影掠过
而你微笑的面容极浅极淡
逐渐隐没在日落后的群岚
遂翻开那发黄的扉页
命运将它装订得极为拙劣
含着泪
我一读再读
却不得不承认青春是一本太仓促的书
就这样子
他连悲伤都很轻微
都云淡风轻的悲伤
他的创作风格很聚焦
这种事情应该是女生会喜欢的
但我就偏偏我就我就喜欢
我也不知道
然后变成我日后坐姿的养分
或者是我日后创造溯源韵脚时的一个动力
就是原来有这样的诗作风格
那我觉得我应该摸索出自己的一个创作的类型
所以我赋予了诗的结构
有一个相对应的韵脚
把所有的重点放在最后一行或最后一句
变成个人的一种创作风格
接下来是分享下雨的诗
待会你会吓一跳
一样是丝哦
每个人看到的画面感不一样
每个人看到的世界不一样
这个就是所谓风格非常鲜明
而且非常的一致性
甜蜜的复仇
把你的影子加点盐腌起来
风干老的时候下酒没了
就这样子
很惊艳吧
以最少的文字去表达最多的意思
这个就是诗的核心价值
接下来分享的这一首是下雨的拥抱
风是黑暗
门缝是睡
冷淡和懂是雨
突然是看见混淆
叫做房间
露向海岸线
身体是流沙
诗是冰块
猫轻微
但水鸟是时间
群的海岸
虚线的火焰预言消灭刮胡深陷斑点的感官感官
你是雾
我是酒馆
是不是很特别
我完全是另外一种创作风格
他的文字行进间有一种简洁的效果
有点像蒙太奇的剪接
他的诗比较像都会感的动作片
词句跟词句的想象跳跃很快
那另外席慕蓉的诗比较像文艺爱情片
就轻轻柔柔
云淡风轻
它也不简洁
不简洁又不简洁的美啊
但是简洁有简洁的创意
这是截然不同的创作风格
夏雨跟席慕蓉的诗最大的差距在于
下雨的诗有文字张力
适合进行导读跟咀嚼的空间
但席梦蓉的诗没有
他就很唯美
很文艺
基本上比较不需要逐句的去导读
像刚刚那时候拥抱风是黑暗
门缝是睡光
这八个字
你知道这画面感的跳跃有多大吗
风是黑暗
门缝是税
他把税形容成门缝或是用门缝是譬喻税
很特别
重点是第三句冷淡和懂是雨是雨哦
所以风跟雨都有了诶
有环境音哦
有环境音了
突然看见混淆叫做房间
好耐人寻味哦
好接下来肉像海岸线
沙漏的肉
身体是流沙
诗是冰块猫轻微
但水鸟是时间
刚刚有房间
有时间有风有雨
寻的海滩
虚线的火焰
这也太天马行空了吧
虚线来譬喻火焰
再来预言下面刮胡深陷
完全一头雾水
还有斑点的感官感官
你是雾
我是酒馆
怎么理解呢
告诉各位同学看他的标题叫做拥抱风
拥抱黑暗门缝
拥抱水
有些诗作呢你要对他的标题
因为它的标题就是它的灵魂
他的灵魂定位了
所有的形容都是在衬托那个标题
就像有些时候我会遇到一些学生
就是对歌词创作有兴趣的一些年轻人
他们都会说他们的书桌上摆了一本我的韵脚诗
就是创作的时候想不出来
那就翻一翻
翻几页去开拓他的文字视野
那这个一样啊
但现在没有
以前我创作的时候
我的书桌上会有几本诗人的作品
那下雨的诗就是其中一本
就是这样子去加深自己歌词文字的重量
看到不同的世界
很多的主观是
因为非常多的客观因素去行贿了你
对事物判断的一个能力
会慢慢累积出你身后的文字能量
这也就是说
课堂里我可能天马行空的分享很多领域的知识
有时候聊到当代艺术
甚至于书法建筑
甚至还有新作
可能同学们觉得很奇怪
怎么星座跟创作有关
星座跟创作没有直接的关系
但是跟你独立判断的思考有关系
而独立判断的思考会影响你作品的风格
所以呢
他还是间接的有关系
那我们再分享一下之前课堂上讲过的星座
之前不是跟大家讲过吗
星座很多的破绽跟盲点
因为它既然是统计学
但绝大多数的星座所谓的专家
他拿不出数据来说服我们
他没有去做田野调查
比如说全国范围内的律师公会去做收集资料哦
那我们有理由相信律师这种理科的性格哦
什么星座偏多
或者是所有的运动协会
去把他所有运动员的大数据
不管是河北山东河南的做个统计学
然后来判断说怎么样的一个星座的性格
对于运动的体现最热衷
对运动的学习能力最强
他们并没有这么做
所以呢我就觉得说星座这个论述和观点
他缺少了统计学去支撑
可是重点是可视哦
当初我继续研究下去的时候
我又发现星座其实是有依据的
是峰回路转
因为我查到一个数据
就是法国二次大战的时候再做个统计
他们发现某一个季节出生的新兵
作战上特别的勇敢
战场上的表现最为勇敢
那是为什么呢
哦原来我们人体在母亲的怀里受孕的时候
快出生的那个季节
季节会影响一个人的气质
气质会反映在个性上
个性会凸显了你对植物类别的选项
那就又好像跟星座有关的
因为一年四季春夏秋冬
那可能冬天出生的小朋友或夏天出生的小朋友
跟秋天出生的小朋友先天上的性格就不一样了
因为你在受孕的晚期
快出生的那几个月
你的身体里面感受得到季节的变化
不管是酷寒还是燥热
因为你人体在感官感知的那几个月
气候已经影响了你身体的变化
外在的因素会影响心里面会影响生理
所以呢不同季节出生的小朋友
它会有具备先天性的性格
那是春夏秋冬造成的
是季节是温度造成的
而不是我之前讲的几颗星
根本不相关的狮子座造成的
所以你反推回来哦
诶星座好像又有依据了
但是他依据不是离我们几万光年远的那个星球
是最实在反映在我们身体里面
受孕的晚期
受孕的晚期遇到的天后
而这个天后会影响一个人的个性
就像北方的民族的个性
什么东北人性格比较豪爽
然后南方的姑娘比较温柔婉约
是不是这样子
原来还绕了半天
星座是有依据的
恍然大悟
是因为我研究的精神是一路的追踪
因为我就觉得说
可是又觉得星座好像有某种程度的可靠
那这个可靠的论点在哪里
终于被我查到线索
就是我讲到的受孕晚期的气候影响
一个人的气质
气质形象出性格
性格会决定职业类别的选项
所以同学们记得请说出自己
独立判断的能力是非常非常重要的
这个会帮助到我们的创作风格的确认